a bunch of questions
um the movie's coming out soon when do
you actually finish when are you getting
your final VFX shots or will it be the
day before we will finish the movie uh
the day before it releases that's right
uh we're constantly tweaking getting
those last visual effects shots in and
honing music and all that stuff but
we're almost done yeah that was a that
was a joke answer it's gonna be maybe
before the end of the year yeah a couple
couple weeks from right there well the
thing that's close the thing that people
don't realize is it's when you finally
get the final VFX shots you can cut a
trailer unlike the others because you
have the shots that's right you know
it's a it's a completely different Beast
it totally is and you know we've been
real sticklers about the look of this
thing and trying to get it to a place
that we're all really happy with and
fortunately the studio and the VFX
vendors have been incredibly supportive
in that in that case one of the things
about dragons usually depicted in um
movies and television is you have uh two
uh legs I mean two feet and uh like the
hand like it's basically not what you
guys are doing you're doing what's
really D which is four leg you know what
I mean yes can you can you talk about
how you decided on the design of the
dragons and being a little you know more
accurate to what people know who played
D but we start with the lore we start
with you know what's in D and D yeah
they have very specific
um descriptions and specifications of
what each dragon is
and uh we have a red dragon in this and
uh so we started with with what comes
out of uh of the books and all that but
then we added our own sort of
unique tweaks to to the uh
characteristics of the Dragon
part of it is you know we wanted to
differentiate itself from all the
dragons that are out there in popular
culture right now so we had
people love dragons people of dinosaurs
they love they love these big Mammoth
creatures and we knew we needed to make
it uh something that sets itself apart a
little bit from what people are used to
in in uh and because it's DND we have
the license to do that because it's all
about kind of finding that that unique
that unique aesthetic
um so we're really closely with the
Wizards on the look of the Dragons as
well
they are kind of like their wizards no
they were very involved though in the
actual design of the dragon and they
were gave us tremendously wait a ton of
stuff in the lore but the dragons
themselves there was so much like lore
specific stuff about exactly where the
fin goes and exactly how the the thumb
works and it was it was really wild it
was really fun diving into that with
them because they've done it for you
know 50 years to make the coolest
dragons yeah and our hero dragon our red
dragon
um is actually based on a character in
The Lord so it's not we're not totally
deviating from what people want uh in
the clip that you showed at ccxp
yesterday which may have been similar or
the same clip you showed at San Diego I
missed that the panel in San Diego I'm
not 100 you obviously homage and Nod to
the Animated Series
um which the crowd here lost their minds
um and I'm just curious I can't I'm I
was so excited to see that footage is
there any other Easter eggs that could
be
um in the movie uh as allusions to the
80s I'm just talking about new Dragon's
Lair
um look we we filled this thing with
Easter eggs but we also know that this
is the very beginning of our our journey
if we're lucky knock on wood so you know
I think there's there's a there's a big
Runway and a lot of room to continue to
sort of introduce fan favorites
including you know some of the more
iconic creatures and monsters
um but you know we didn't want to to be
a total kitchen sink yeah for geeks but
I will say that the reaction to the 80s
characters here and in England is really
wild because you find places that that
show really lived and has lived on
generationally so that dads are showing
to their kids and people have like
really been with that show for a long
time and here that was outrageous
the funny thing about those characters
is it's a cartoon and their costumes are
pretty Broad and bright and colorful and
we wanted our movie to live in somewhat
the real world so we had to sort of tone
down some of the color palette from the
cartoon but they're still recognizable
as those cartoon characters I lost it
when I saw that that's awesome
um I already have to rap I'm just going
to say that uh congratulations on the
reaction down here I really can't wait
to see the film thank you so much thank
you appreciate it